من مكه الى الرياض خاض المواطن السعودي
عبد الرحيم السلمي رحله امل والهام واضع
لعقته التي اصيب بها خلف ظهره مؤكدا ان لا
ياس بعد الاعاقه عبد الرحيم قطع نحو 900
كم في 32 يوما وهو على مشارف الوصول الى
الرياض في هذه الايام يطمح بالوصول اليها
رغم تعب الطريق وضجت مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي بفيديوهات عبد الرحيم الذي تحدى
الاعاقه سيرا على راحلته التي نقلته من
مكه الى الرياض وهو بكامل نشاطه في سبيل
مواصله الرحله اليوم سيكون معنا عبد
الرحيم للحديث عن الرحله والالهام والامل
وكيف تحدى الاعاقه ليكون مثالا اعلى
للجميع الاصحاء منهم قبل ذوي الهمم
[موسيقى]
عبد الرحيم يعني تحديت الاعاقه وقررت خوض
رحله من مكه الى الرياض وهي ليست بالرحله
السهله حدثنا اكثر عن فكره هذه الرحله
والهدف منها
الهدف من الرحله طبعا اسم الرحله الاعاقه
عندي اعاقه بذكر فوق الركبه رجل اليمنى
والحمد لله هدفي من الرحله
لاخواني ذو البتور والاحتيالات الخاصه
كافه
من مكه الى
العاصمه الرياض
[موسيقى]
وهي مطيعه ولا مطيعه يا عبد الرحيم
مطيع مطيع مذكر طيب عبد الرحيم انت يعني
استشرت الطبيب قبل هذه الرحله نتحدث عن
رحله طويله يعني خصوصا انه فيها خطور
خطوره الوقوع من الناقه
نعم
طبي شامل الحمد لله كل شيء سليم وبعدين
عندي خلفيه في طلوع على الابل وما في اي
صعوبه
الانسان اذا انه نوى على شيء يعمله بكل
اصرار
اكيد يعني الحمد لله
عبد الرحيم وين الوجهه بعد الرياض كمان رح
تكمل بالناقه لا ان شاء الله انه الان اول
شيء شكرا للاخوانة وزاره الرياضه انتظر
منهم
يوجهوني للموقع
اللي اوصل له
وهنا تنتهي الرحله
[موسيقى]